el periodista ruso dmitri murátov es uno
de los ganadores del premio nobel de la
paz- 2021 recibe el galardón por
salvaguardar la libertad de expresión
algo que el comité del nobel considera
indispensable para la democracia
duradera
murátov es director de nóvaya gazeta
donde trabajaba la famosa periodista
anna politkóvskaya asesinada hace ahora
15 años un hato fundó el periódico
nóvaya gazeta en el año 1993 y sigue
siendo su principal impulsor la
publicación es a día de hoy una de las
más críticas con el kremlin y es
conocida por sus investigaciones en
profundidad sobre temas muy difíciles
como las violaciones de los derechos
humanos los abusos del poder y la
corrupción en el gobierno ruso sus
reporteros han informado ampliamente
sobre los asesinatos y los desaparecidos
en el cáucaso y recientemente han
desvelado la persecución de los
homosexuales en chechenia hasta el
kremlin ha felicitado a morató por el
premio ensalzando que al fin y al cabo
trabaja persistentemente de acuerdo con
sus propios ideales